welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is Eric Trexler I am the
special temporary primary host of the
show and today I'm joined by Greg
Knuckles he is currently the permanent
guest co-host for the time being Greg
how you doing today I'm doing well how
are you I am doing great uh now I know
because this is a multimedia experience
some people are going to say Eric Greg
you look exactly the way you looked last
week same clothes same demeanor uh the
reason is uh this is a family values
podcast we've always been very open
about that very proud of that in fact
and as part of a family values podcast
we have to value our families so what
that means is we want to spend some time
for Thanksgiving with our loved ones and
uh so we recorded both of these episodes
on the same day
but if you're listening at home
you're getting this on if you're
listening it right when it comes out
which you should we do recommend if you
want the freshest podcast you should
listen the day it comes out uh you're
listening on November 28th and that's an
important day because it's the final day
of the mass research review Black Friday
sale these are the lowest prices of the
year for the mass research review which
comes out the first of the month every
single month like clockwork we've been
doing it for years never late always a
really great PDF usually like 100 150
pages long tons of nutrition and
exercise research very practical always
focus on how we can use this information
to get bigger stronger faster leaner
Etc so the mass research review it's
articles it's really brief skimmable
research briefs that we introduced
within the last year or so it's audio
discussions it's video lectures
everything you could ever want from me
and Greg and our good friends Dr Mike
zordos and Dr Dr Eric Helms so it's the
last day of the sale like I said lowest
prices of the year
and this cell this sale benefits charity
so so we are going to be making a
donation uh with a portion of the
proceeds from this sale that is going to
go to a charity that fights hunger uh
and uh it's a food bank charity to make
sure that people are getting fed over
the holiday season so a really really
good cause uh now there are other ways
to support the show if any listeners
feel so inclined you could like rate or
subscribe wherever you get the show you
could join our email newsletter which
sends out every Wednesday we send a
research update with some really helpful
information so you can figure that out
and get on that list over at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter if
you're looking for one-on-one virtual
coaching we do offer that you can learn
more at Stronger by science.com coaching
you want to get a discount on your
supplements you go to
bulksupplements.com and you use the
checkout code SBS pod it gets you a five
percent discount on your entire order uh
and of course you could check out the
macro Factor Diet app which we
co-developed with a talented team of
developers it does offer a free trial so
you can take it for a spin see if you
like it and we think you're going to
love it and if you do make sure you
stick around and subscribe for macro
Factor now this is going to be another q
a episode so we've got some great
questions we get these from the Facebook
group Stronger by science Community is
the name of that Facebook group
we also get these questions from the
stronger by science subreddit so if you
want to contribute a question in the
future the best way to do that is to
join one or both of those communities
and keep an eye out for the Q a threads
that come up periodically so Greg where
are we starting here yeah so uh let's
let's uh start in the subreddit uh there
was a question by oryx math uh actually
two questions so uh the first
um
essentially asks I was gonna say there's
no way you're going to read that
question verbatimer no I don't uh I
don't I don't read that well
um but but yeah so it's essentially
asking like hey it seems like a lot of
training programs out there are very
powerlifting influenced powerlifting
inspired
um so they do plenty of squat binge
deadlift which are great exercises in
their own right but if uh if you and I
wanted to design kind of a
you know core set of exercises for
people who you know are are trying to
get bigger and stronger but in more of a
recreational way like you don't really
want to compete in bodybuilding don't
really want to compete in power lifting
um you know just just generally trying
to get bigger stronger but also like
healthier be able to move well uh Etc
um what would those core exercises be
and uh uh he he they specify
um we were not saying that these are the
only exercises someone would ever do in
a program and uh they also encouraged us
to not be too vague or general about it
so not say something like some sort of
hip hinge movement or some sort of
horizontal pulling movement uh like like
be specific like if you had to choose a
a group of of specific exercises that
you put out in the world and said hey
you're trying to get big and strong
these are the ones you should kind of
focus on uh what what would those be
oh man God
that's tough because I didn't read this
question beforehand so I didn't have
time to like put together a kind of
quick thing I can I can take the first
swipe yeah you go first yeah so I I do
think that the
um
in in Broad strokes The General setup of
hey we're gonna have a horizontal push
we're gonna have a vertical push we're
gonna have a horizontal pull we're gonna
have a vertical pull we're gonna have
some sort of knee dominant lower body
exercise and some sort of hip dominant
lower body exercise
um shout out to Ian King he was the
person who who uh popularized that
General conception of of grouping things
by movement more so than like muscle
um I'm sure he wasn't the first person
with the idea he's definitely the person
who popularized it and I don't think he
gets as much credit in the industry as
he deserves anymore so uh shout outs to
Ian King but anyways um I I do think
that that's a good way to uh set up most
General programs uh but to to not be too
vague to give some some specific
exercises that I would slot in there for
people who are just generally trying to
get stronger build some muscle but with
more of like a a hobbyist kind of like
Jim General Health perspective for the
horizontal push I would probably go with
weighted push-ups potentially with an
extended range of motion so like feet on
the ground hands elevated so your chest
can get a little bit lower
um gives you a slightly longer range of
motion than you have with bench press
also lets your scapulae move uh move
freely so you can you know have some
good uh
scapulohumeral Rhythm uh as it were get
some serratus work in so I'd probably go
with uh with push-ups which then as you
get strong you can add some band
resistance or or some other form of
resistance for the Vertical Press
I would probably go with either push
press or a single armed uh dumbbell
press I think both are excellent
um for push press I like that more than
just a barbell overhead press because it
doesn't have as funky of a strength
curve like a barbell overhead press
basically if you can get it past your
forehead it's easy
um
with a with a push press once you get
pretty coordinated at it you can kind of
tune your leg Drive such that you have a
pretty smooth uh strength curve
throughout the entire movement so I I
just prefer push press and then with uh
with the single arm dumbbell overhead
press
especially if you have kind of cranky
shoulders that don't like you a ton you
you have just way more degrees of
freedom where you can find a hand
position a shoulder position an elbow
position that just helps everything line
up right for that press to feel good
um so yeah of the two I think I'd
probably go with the single arm dumbbell
overhead press but with with push press
as also a strong contender
for the horizontal pull I would probably
go with a single arm dumbbell row just
so you have a bit of of like rotational
work uh as well but I don't know I don't
have that strong of opinions about Rose
in general so if I had to choose one it
would it would probably be a single arm
dumbbell row but there there are plenty
of good options I think I will just
default to the general yeah some sort of
row
um for the vertical pull
I would probably just go with like
neutral grip Pull-Ups for people who can
do pull-ups for people who can't do
pull-ups probably neutral grip pull
Downs
um for the
hip dominant lower body exercise
probably gonna go with trap bar
deadlifts I think they're easier to
learn than a barbell deadlift
um
they also are just like more
accommodating of more degrees of freedom
like I think a lot of people uh struggle
with a barbell deadlift because you want
to keep the bar really close to your
body
um but that's generally going to involve
scraping the [ __ ] out of your shins
which if you're a power lifter that's
cool like you get uh you get scars on
your shins and wear them as a badge of
pride a lot of people don't want big big
scars all the way up and down their
shins
um and so you know you get the bar
further in front of you then you kind of
get get further over it get out of
position like eh I don't know I I think
the barbell deadlift is a great movement
but I think that for most people the the
trap bar is just easier to learn also
has a neutral handle so it's it's easier
to hold on to without a mix grip or
straps
um
and yeah like uh people people can have
more General degrees of freedom to find
kind of the ratio of knee extension to
hip extension uh Force strength that
that makes the most sense for them
um but yeah I I just really like trap
bar deadlift uh and then for the quad
dominant one since
um you know since the trap bar deadlift
is a little bit more need dominant than
a lot of hip dominant lower body
exercises I'm gonna go with a slightly
more hip dominant knee dominant lower
body exercise for the knee dominant one
uh and I would probably go with like a
rear leg elevated split squat
um particularly if if your lead foot is
is out in front a pretty decent way
um still gonna blow up your quads but
you'll you'll also uh get a lot of get a
lot of glute work from it as well
um
so yeah those those are those are the
six I would probably go for so just to
reiterate that's uh push-ups
particularly hand elevated push-ups
think they're great uh single arm
dumbbell overhead press neutral grip
pull up or pull down uh single arm
dumbbell row
um trap bar deadlift and uh rear leg
elevated split squats
yeah I there's a lot of agreement uh I
would agree with quite a few of those
but what I want to do to make this
useful is recommend some Alternatives
that are high on my list
uh I think with uh flat press uh some
kind of push-up variation was my first
choice
um but if I wasn't gonna do that maybe I
would do a low incline dumbbell press
um that would be kind of my second
choice
um
I I agree fully actually about uh for a
vertical pull uh doing a neutral grip
pull-up I think would be my number one
my number two might be a
maybe a chin up just to get more biceps
in the mix
um
when it comes to rows what I've been
doing lately is kind of an interesting
setup that I've just kind of found my
way toward uh just because I've been
babying my hip and lower back but I I do
it like an inverted row um like a rack
chin almost where I get into the squat
rack I lay the bar across the safety
pins elevate my feet and I'm basically
doing like a horizontal type of Pull-Up
but I've I've been putting the little uh
handles for like the cable machines
such that they are perpendicular to the
bar I've been kind of sliding them over
the bar so what it what it allows me to
do is It's Over Control a little bit
Yeah so it's a neutral grip with a
really nice range of motion
um I think a lot of people would really
like that variation I've surely didn't
come up with the idea I don't think you
could possibly create something that has
been created before in the gym
um but but I've never seen anyone do it
and I think it's really nice so that'd
be my row with overhead press we've
talked about this before I'm a big fan
of the single arm dumbbell overhead
press but I also like
I would make the controversial argument
that I'm not sure that you necessarily
need an overhead press in all programs
yeah I I don't I don't disagree with
that so like if I was gonna drop one
category like the if I was gonna choose
an overhead press that's the one I'd go
with but I'd also encourage people to
say like or to at least consider
is there a reason why I need to be do
doing overhead pressing because I would
actually say I'd rather do a low incline
press and a high incline press rather
than like a flat and a completely
overhead or or just sub out the overhead
pressing for something like leg raises
yeah just just who you're not completely
neglecting your abs and hip flexors or
or or
um you know the the hypothetical was
that you're in a really well-equipped
gym maybe even doing like uh a husafel
stone carry or Atlas Stone pickups uh or
doing uh like a yoke carry like
something that's just going to be
massive bang for your buck get a lot of
different muscle groups involved I I
would uh I would probably go with one of
those over an overhead press I I but but
you know kind of just depends what
you're looking for and what you feel
really confident about doing in the gym
um an alternative to the the trap bar
deadlift I really like
um single leg rdls which I typically do
with either a dumbbell or a kettlebell
that that was that was my number two
yeah I really like that variation uh for
a quad dominant exercise I've always
been really partial to walking lunges uh
I think for a lot of people it's a very
intuitive quad focused exercise that
they can pick up but you still get
plenty of really good glue deck glued
activity in there as well really nice
contribution from the glutes depending
on the length of stride that you're
using
um I think I've I think I've covered all
of them right yeah yeah so so those are
some other options to keep in mind but
you know the general ideas you know when
people make these hypotheticals uh there
there are these kind of classic
categories of exercises to select from
but it's always important to make sure
you you consider like what are the
categories that are most critical to me
for my purposes now for a general
question you get a general answer but
yeah I think one of my um
one of my takes that I
not not really willing to fight over
because I don't care enough but I think
some people put overhead pressing on
their program out of a sense of
obligation when in reality they just
maybe don't even need it when you look
at all of the other
pushing and pulling that they're doing
like for a lot of folks I look at their
program and I say the only thing we
really need in here to round out your
your shoulder contribution here it's
just like a couple lateral raises and we
should be fine
um but yeah that's my two cents sweet
um all right so uh oryx Math's second
question was uh suppose again we have a
trainee who doesn't participate in any
sport but just who but who just wanted
to be quote generally strong and fit and
athletic if you are going to give them a
handful of tests to do say every 12
weeks uh to test and track how quote
generally strong and fit and athletic
they are what would those tests be a
made-up example might be something like
a one rep max deadlift 12 rep max squat
one rep max push press 100 meter dash
what you you get the idea uh doesn't
necessarily have to be a definitive
complete list just some tests that come
to mind call it the stronger by science
combine
oh boy what are what are some of the
ones that come to mind for you
um
um for literally no reason at all I'm
gonna say the two mile run because well
I there's a reason I was always good at
the two mile run but but I I think one
mile is not quite long enough to really
tap into to what I'd be looking for is
like a quick test of of endurance I
think a one one mile you can kind of
just push through it and I I'd like to
see a slightly longer distance covered
if I'm looking for endurance performance
so I'd say a two mile run would be in
there I would say
um
maybe like of three rep max on like the
squat and the bench press maybe throw
both of those in there
um
I think you could throw in uh just a Max
reps on like either pull-ups or chin-ups
throw that into the mix
um
and then I would say vertical jump test
yeah there there's not much in there
that I disagree with
um
for the for the aerobic endurance one I
I might potentially even go a little bit
longer like a 5k or like a five mile run
yeah
um you know just to make sure that you
are like really testing
um
uh like aerobic fitness and not just
like mostly or like a large proportion
anaerobic yeah some people just like
Sprint the last three minutes they're
mild tests and then puke their guts out
yeah that's not really what we're
getting at yeah so I I would go
something like that and I would go
further down as well so got a test of
aerobic fitness test of anaerobic
Fitness like a 400 or 800
um yeah which that's not gonna be fun no
one no one enjoys that but hey testing
your anaerobic Fitness sucks everyone
hates it it's terrible but uh that's
that's just how it is uh and then
even a step further down maybe like a 40
meter or 100 meter dash
um a lot more running than I thought out
of you well so I I'm I'm trying to split
it into like I'm trying to be pretty
systematic about like Hey we're gonna
test uh maximal speed like because this
said strong and fit and athletic I think
I think speed is important
um
so like a in a hundred meter test your
your take off to some extent but also
top end speed
um you know for 800 for anaerobic
Fitness something longer for aerobic
fitness cool like now you have your your
velocity and just kind of like Energy
System stuff taken care of
um
I I would I would also probably go with
either a vertical jump or standing broad
jump
um yeah just something to test uh like
Explosive Performance from kind of a
standstill
um so which is slightly distinct from
from maximal velocity
uh and one of the ones that that
oryxmath uh suggested here as well is a
max distance Med ball throw which I
quite like
um both the chest pass variety and the
kind of like
overhead toss variety
um to to look at like Explosive
Performance for both the upper body and
for kind of like hip hinging stuff uh I
think both of those are very good
and then uh you got strength strength
endurance and uh flexibility uh from
there so for strength
yeah I think I think like a three rep
max squat or binge press or maybe bench
press or deadlift would get the job done
um strength endurance
I mean you wouldn't want to do this
every 12 weeks but I I think it's hard
to beat like a 20 rep max squat test
um see I went with the pull-ups because
I wouldn't do that to a person it's so
brutal I mean I think I think pull-ups
would also be very good for that as well
that also kind of gets you some some
like strength to weight ratio stuff in
there as well
um
and then yeah uh
I just some general flexibility tests I
don't know there there are plenty of
just batteries to assess flexibility in
different planes so just just pick one
of those and go with it yeah
um yeah I probably wouldn't wouldn't
want to do all of that every 12 weeks
but if you if you wanted to put yourself
through a battery of tests that would
probably take about a week to complete
counting the the rest time you need to
build in between testing sessions that
you wanted to maybe repeat yearly just
as kind of a check-in to see where
you're at
um that's that that's probably the the
list that I would go with you know I'm
an industrious fellow and this is giving
me an idea so imagine for maybe like a
five cone test as well agility change of
Direction yeah yeah
I have a wacky idea it's the SBS combine
right that's the nature of the question
what if we do an annual combine
and then you know and it's all you know
you submit videos of your testing
and then we do kind of like a fantasy
Fitness League instead of like Fantasy
Football Fantasy Baseball uh and you
based on the Combine results you draft a
team and uh and then you uh you know we
have some competitive fitness challenges
throughout the year maybe we partner
with like DraftKings or some other big
gambling site uh we're open to
sponsorships from any any companies that
are worth hundreds of millions of
dollars I mean I've really got the gears
turning here I think we could we could
do something with this I do think it
would be fun if there was
so I think one of the I think one of the
drawbacks of most like competitive
Fitness Pursuits be that weightlifting
powerlifting uh CrossFit even really
almost everything but strong man you
don't you don't get the head to head you
know
um and so I I think I think a pretty
cool I mean it wouldn't be that cool of
a sport like it wouldn't be as cool as
like basketball or football but if if
you wanted to make competitive Fitness
more interesting like I tuned into into
the CrossFit games uh maybe like four or
five years ago it was
um it was retroning's last win actually
um so I guess that was a while ago now
but anyway like I like I could
appreciate how fit all of the
competitors were like it was truly
impressive
um but it was also truly mind-numbingly
boring television yeah
um but I think if there was if there was
more of like a head-to-head aspect with
maybe like a bracket element where you
know maybe it's it's the type of thing
where there's a list of of 50 events you
could compete in and it's like a best of
five where
um you know the like one person chooses
the first event you compete at uh should
be tailored to their strengths the other
person's weaknesses the next person
chooses an event
um and if it goes 2-2 you kick it to the
audience and say hey what what do you
want to see for the tiebreaker
um so yeah it would it would be like all
head-to-head competition there would be
the the human element of you know like
when you choose the event you're looking
the other person in the eye and being
like I'm gonna kick your ass here yeah
um
I I think that if if you were to do a
competitive fitness competition that
would be a more engaging way to set it
up all right well the ball's in your
court uh five Kings to be clear I still
think that would suck like I I I
wouldn't watch it but I I think that it
would be pretty entertaining what you're
saying is you wouldn't watch it but it
might be more entertaining than like
eight percent of what's currently being
consumed is entertainment yeah I think
it would be 20 less entertaining than
strong man and 400 percent more
entertaining than powerlifting
okay
look I I love the sport of power lifting
you're never gonna catch me watching a
live stream for a whole day yeah zero
chance
um but but if you if you like the
support the sport and want to support it
and uh help it grow
yeah watch the live stream yeah so I
will say like for for big private events
with like big prize pools that are you
know trying to make sure that like the
best lifters get paid like the people
who really drive the sport forward put a
lot put a lot into it
um I will often pay for the live stream
just to kind of support the event and
and not watch a second of it but I'm
like yeah it seems like a good thing to
do yeah
um all right moving on the dancing
Wireless
uh asks about your transition to a vegan
diet Eric
um Eric mentioned on the Pod he's now
fully vegan I'm curious if he's made any
changes to his diet or training
parentheses other than obviously not
eating any animal products close
parentheses since making the switch or
if he's noticed any difference in
performance or recovery from the gym uh
are there any things like
supplementation or anything you
particularly pay attention to in your
diet uh now that you've made the switch
yeah I haven't really noticed anything
with performance or recovery but one
thing I've noticed is that
like from the moment my eyes close at
night until I wake up
erection
the whole night
that's that's a throwback for people who
listen to like episode 20 of the podcast
I should contextualize that that is a
joke uh about there is a documentary
called The Game Changers that uh was all
about like very plant forward diets uh
in many cases vegan diets um you know
but pretty much anything under the
plant-based umbrella but like there's
such a a robust literature one could
draw upon to make
sound evidence-based points in that
documentary but instead they just had
this guy who's like dude you're gonna
have so many erections at night if
you're on a vegan diet because your
vascular system is off the charts and so
like they they allocated like
maybe a good 15 minutes of that
documentary to just like assessing
nocturnal
erections for absolutely no reason uh
but anyway no uh that was a joke uh I
haven't really noticed anything
different
um which is nice because I felt very
good and very healthy prior and yeah
nothing's really changed uh performance
is similar recovery similar uh food
choices are different but not really
that big a deal there are some
restaurants where it's just kind of
challenging to find like very very easy
easy in most places to find a vegetarian
option uh considerably more challenging
at some places to find a vegan option uh
I've been training exactly the same way
I normally do I've been ramping it up a
little bit um just because I've been
feeling uh like I have more
more capacity to really lean into my
training a little bit harder
um so training I've been ramping that up
but it feels exactly the same no issues
or benefits really when it comes to
recovery changes to my diet I mean
obviously the food sources are very
different I'm just trying to be a little
bit more
mindful of
uh making sure I have some presence of
complementary protein sources one thing
I will acknowledge like the the switch
has not been challenging but one thing I
will acknowledge is uh soy protein as
kind of an added protein source and a
lot of uh Foods marketed toward vegans I
think some people are shying away from
soy for a variety of reasons I think a
lot of that is not really driven by
science but more driven by consumer
sentiment uh you know the old uh the the
concept of a soy boy and all of the like
phytoestrogens I think people are really
ramping down their their
uh eagerness to add soy as a protein
Source into some of these foods and a
lot of them are using pea protein
instead I'm noticing and pea protein is
very good
um but pea protein in terms of the amino
acid profile you would kind of like to
even that out a little bit with a
complementary Source
um like I think soy if I'm not mistaken
has a slightly more favorable kind of
more comprehensive amino acid profile so
I guess uh the biggest thing is that I
just try to focus on having a greater
diversity of protein sources so I try to
get some pea protein I try to get some
rice protein I try to get some soy
protein I really try to mix it up a
little bit and I mentioned on the last
episode I just ordered uh a really big
shipment of
pea protein rice protein and soy protein
from bulksupplements.com and I'm just
going to mix them all together and be
like all right base is covered we're
good here so I'll let the I'll let the
listeners know how that turns out but
really the only difference is that I've
been because I I was always taking uh
algae oil as a source of EPA and DHA
which would colloquially we might call
fish oil but algae oil is a really good
vegan source of those fatty acids I've
always taken a multivitamin a few times
a week sometimes I just forget so I've
continued to do those things which
become relatively more noteworthy when
you're on a vegan diet
um just because you have issues with
certain micronutrients getting in the
diet and then other issues with just the
bioavailability of certain food
combinations kind of absorbing all those
micronutrients so I I I was going to ask
about like B12 iron because you're not
getting heme bound iron any more like
calcium stuff like that but yeah I mean
technically like
so I take a multivitamin that is
specifically formulated for males and
they often contain little to no iron
yeah uh I'm playing that by ear I feel
like with iron you can kind of let
anemia symptoms kind of let you know how
you're doing yeah
um that's not a medical recommendation
by the way but I mean like I haven't
really gone out of my way to get a whole
bunch of extra iron in my diet
um
but but yeah I still take the
multivitamins still take the the algae
oil and the multivitamins obviously
taking care of B12
um but yeah yeah I mean I I wouldn't
think that for you the iron would be an
issue like I
I don't know the statistics right off
the top of my head but my my
understanding is that like iron
deficiency issues in males are
close to non-existent right that's
that's more of like a not exclusively
like there there are certainly anemic
men but it's it's more of like a women's
health issue for the most part
um yeah that might be something to pay
closer attention to once you once you
get back into running and you're you're
lysine more of your your blood cells but
yeah like yeah that all makes sense yeah
all right uh moving on here this is
going to be an interesting one I'm
curious to see your take on this uh
we've got a question from Isaac Isaac
says what are your thoughts on the
recent trend of optimizing exercises in
order to take advantage of anatomy
before I give an answer Greg I want to
bounce this off you and see if I'm
interpreting the question correctly does
do you think they're getting at the idea
of like working with kind of
individualizing uh your exercise
selection and exercise execution based
on kind of individual level differences
in anatomy like anatomical structure
um is that how you read it or do you
read it with in a different way I read
it
more in terms of the the content that's
like gotten pretty popular on Instagram
that's just like hey guess what uh uh
preacher curls suck they actually don't
build your biceps at all
um but also here's like a a slight tweak
on like a bicep curl variation that's
going to be like four times as effective
for biceps growth like that that's
that's how I read it interesting so so
the idea with with that type of content
is that it's supposed to be
generalizable across the board like no
matter who you are I believe I mean if
if uh
if I'm interpreting
what I presume to be the the
connotations of this question yes
interesting I'm curious how would you
answer this question what are you
thinking
um so because you're the exercise guy
my first thought is that I already
answered this I think I think back in
episode
70
um so I this question from Isaac I I
already responded to him in the group
um but yeah
uh
I don't see the episode number on on the
SBS pod but it's the one it's the
episode that came out December 16th uh
2021 so about a year ago uh but yeah my
general perspective is that like
I don't think so I
I'm not opposed to the general concept
of people being like hey based on the
the general line of pull for this muscle
and the resistance curve of the exercise
and the strength curve of this
particular joint action
um you know maybe this exercise is a
little bit better than this other like
variation of a similar exercise and so
uh you know if if you have been
struggling with bicep curls or like if
you've been struggling with bicep growth
um you know maybe maybe give this other
exercise a shot instead of preacher
curls if preacher curls aren't working
out for you like I think that that's
um a perfectly reasonable way to
approach it where you lay out on the
front end
um here's why I assume that this
variation would be better
there is not solid evidence that it's
better but you know there there's kind
of some proxy things that would lead one
to assume that it might be
um and you know it's worth giving a shot
if whatever you're doing isn't producing
the results you want like I think that's
perfectly reasonable
I think a lot of the time it's presented
more in the way of uh what you're doing
currently sucks the exercises people
have been doing to build muscle forever
guess what they they all don't work
um but if you do these little tweaks
that uh yeah like some some proxy
measure might suggest it might be a
little bit better uh yeah maybe we slap
like a EMG sensor on like two people's
biceps at the gym and like the the like
Peak EMG readout was like a little bit
higher and so yeah we're gonna say that
absolutely means that this is way more
effective you're going to grow way more
do we have longitudinal evidence
absolutely not why would you ask
um and yeah so it's pretty rude to ask
that honestly yeah so like it's it's
often presented in a way that is
very unjustifiably confident
um
potentially uh potentially sets people
up for a bit of a nocebo effect because
the thing is like a lot of the like
exercise tweaks that they're suggesting
um kind of presuppose that you're
training like a very well equipped
commercial gym with uh a lot of machines
and like various cable setups and
various handles and all of that stuff at
your disposal
um so like there have been people
wandering into the stronger by science
Facebook group saying like hey like I I
see this post about how like this lat
exercise is going to be way more
effective than just you know doing
pull-ups or or regular pull downs but
like I don't have this machine in my
home gym or like my relatively poorly
equipped small commercial gym and so
like oh no I'm [ __ ] I'm never going to
be able to build my lats what should I
do
um and so I I think when it's presented
like that in a very like very
unjustifiably overconfident way
um in Fitness no two two to an extent
that is not just possible but likely to
induce
um potentially a nocebo effect or at
least like a feeling of anxiety in
people who are trying to maximize
hypertrophy but don't just train in the
perfect bodybuilding gym
um I'm not I'm not crazy about that uh
and also just like from from a research
perspective like there's not research on
on a lot of this [ __ ]
um like I think uh I think the first
longitudinal study comparing whether uh
incline binge did actually build your
upper pecs better than flatbench was
published like 18 months ago like that
that's the state of the literature so
you know if if we're talking about two
two like if we're if we're talking about
comparing like uh preacher curls to some
variation of bicep curls that 12 humans
in existence have ever done like no
there's nothing solid you could actually
point to to say yes this is this is
absolutely better so yeah in
in principle I'm not I'm not against the
concept
um but I think the way that those ideas
are often presented uh might do more
harm than good
yeah that makes sense uh I think your
answer is way better than anything I
could have cooked up but like you know
my general approach to you know when if
I'm working with clients and I'm gonna
assume here that our focus is physique
related or you know it's trained to like
generally be strong it's you know we
don't have like a you know specific
exercise that we are training for
because it's what we compete in I try to
take a pretty flexible approach there so
like I'll start with uh you know you use
Anatomy to kind of guide in my opinion
generally speaking what types of
movements ought to be within this
program right so maybe we want to be
doing a press at this kind of angle
pulling at this kind of angle you know
some vertical pulling some horizontal
pulling some incline pressing some flat
press you know you kind of work through
in these General categories right and
ultimately I mean Anatomy has to be a
consent like we don't go in we didn't
start with a blank page and say what
kind of exercises could be done right
like Anatomy is informing the way we
train muscle groups because of what they
do and how they're how the body is built
yeah if you're trying to build your
biceps there should probably be some
elbow flexion exactly whatever exercise
you're doing yeah so so yeah at first I
was a little thrown off by the question
because I was like well how do you
exercise in the absence of considering
Anatomy you know but we've kind of
unpacked the question a little bit but I
like to start out with kind of broader
categories and I like to individualize
from there working with clients
um because you know not everybody's
built exactly the same way not everyone
has the same exercise preferences and
one thing that I think is a little bit
unfortunate you kind of touched on this
a little bit
is that a lot of people are like man I'd
love to individualize my exercise
selection based on my anatomy
but I don't have very expensive EMG
equipment I don't have very expensive
nears equipment how could I possibly
know which exercise
variation is best for me without just
doing like a 16-week controlled trial on
myself and looking at my own growth and
uh
I don't think it's that hard I think
they're overthinking it a little bit you
know like I mean you talk to someone
who's been on the gym floor training
people for a while and I'm not sure if a
commercial grade EMG sensor is going to
tell me much more than if I have you do
an exercise and I say okay at the end of
that set what felt kind of fatigued you
know uh you know two days after we did
that what felt kind of sore and the same
thing with like nears I feel like you
can do a set and be like hey do you have
a pump and where like that's that's
largely gonna tell you what a lot of
these commercial devices are telling you
so I think like you said some some of
that content does have the uh adverse
impact of potentially a little bit of a
nocebo effect and I think another thing
is like some of the content makes it
seem so inaccessible to troubleshoot
your own technique and kind of
individualize your own technique in
terms of exercise selection and then the
actual execution of an exercise you seem
like you had
your brow was furrowed
uh I I thought about saying something
that I
deeply and sincerely believe about this
topic but that would also
I fear be perceived as lobbying a bomb
and I don't want to deal with uh the
potential drama it would cause so I'm
I'm going to be a good boy and not say
what I was thinking you know that's
you're right you don't you never have to
say something that you don't want to say
all right that's the way the show works
but yeah so I I kind of see it as like I
don't know if there's a way to not
optimize your exercise technique and and
execution uh in a way that doesn't take
advantage of anatomy I think that's kind
of the default way to do it is is you
start out with really broad Strokes okay
what muscle are we targeting what
movements actually do that all right so
then you have your broad category of
movements and then you individualize and
troubleshoot from there and say okay
well when we're doing these exercises
which ones are pain-free you know or
disc you know very comfortable to do
minimal discomfort when we're executing
them so which ones are very comfortable
to perform which ones do we enjoy
performing which ones seem to really be
targeting the musculature we're going
for and we can base that on you know
subjective fatigue during the set
soreness a couple days later where we're
getting a pump during an extra you know
and none of those things in isolation
are perfect proxies I should acknowledge
that but overall it's you go through a
workout you can kind of tell what you
hit right and even people who are pretty
new to lifting with a little bit of
guidance you can get that information
out of them and help them kind of pick
up on okay what seems to be working here
what doesn't you go with what works and
you move on from there yeah and another
thing I'll add is just like there are
there there are pretty big
inter-individual differences in in a lot
of this stuff
um I I wrote about a study in Mass maybe
like two like like a year or two ago
um that was looking at the uh the the
relative activation of the hamstrings
following I think like two or three
different hamstrings exercises uh in
like a group of like 20 30 subjects
something like that where they had
um like like individual activation like
or individual EMG data for each head of
the hamstrings for two different
exercises
um and and could essentially compare you
know which exercise caused more uh
activation of like the long head of the
biceps femoris and there was like group
averages but then there were there was
also like a lot of inter-individual
differences like like one of the
exercises was better overall but for
like four out of the 20 individuals the
worst exercise seemed to elicit greater
activation of the long head of their
biceps femoris same general principle
applied with the semitendinosus and my
membranosus so like
yeah like I I ultimately think that the
sort of if you're
if someone is out there proposing that
like this one version of this particular
exercise to Target this particular
muscle is the optimized version that is
just like flatly better than the kind of
normal version in a generalizable sense
and that that will be the case for
essentially everyone
um
I I am extremely doubtful of that
um like I I do think that it's
essentially what you're proposing like
your body is is giving you feedback like
if you have uh especially if you've been
training for a while and you have what
one might colloquially refer to as a
mind muscle connection for whatever
muscle you're training like I mean you
can you can feel like ah is this
exercise giving me a pretty good
contraction for this muscle I'm
targeting is it not uh and does this
exercise is this exercise giving me a
gnarly pump or is it not like that's
that that's that's individualized
feedback you know and it's it's like
relatively low resolution feedback but I
don't know that it's that much lower
resolution than slapping like a single
EMG sensor on a muscle uh and hoping for
the best so yeah and another thing is
people will be like well you know people
that don't train very often they're not
going to be able to really utilize that
that uh bio feedback that relies on this
really good mind muscle connection and
this kind of internal focus of attention
but like
um just like go do some hard [ __ ] that
you don't do very often yeah like do you
have a pre-established excellent mind
muscle connection for like digging a
hole with a shovel
probably not but the next day two days
later you can kind of tell where you're
sore and be like wow I feel wrecked yeah
like you don't have you don't need to
build up like three years worth of
experience with an exercise to say okay
now I can tell what's hard I mean I do
physical things quite frequently that
are are out of the norm and it's it's
not hard to tell in the aftermath what
was working yeah for sure
all right uh quick question here from uh
oh should we go on to this one from
Jason is this one from Jason about uh
this is kind of related because it's
talking about uh you know hypertrophy
and benching at a particular angle so we
can we can kind of stay on theme here so
Jason's got a question when flat
benching is there an advantage for
hypertrophy if you use
a low incline I guess this is saying in
uh
in comparison to Flat benching but using
a low like eight to fifteen percent
incline uh to counteract retracting and
arching so basically uh the hypothesis
that they're they're asking about here
is the idea that flat benching with an
arch or retraction is safer for the
shoulder but puts the delt and upper PEC
at a disadvantage so more PEC is being
used should you use a low incline to
counteract that does that question make
sense to you uh a lot of words yeah
um
ah
yeah so I one don't don't necessarily
object to the premise but question the
premise
um that arching and retracting is really
like that much safer for the shoulder I
don't know maybe it is uh there there's
that's not something with
a ton of research on it or potentially
any research
um at least nothing solid that I've seen
um so yeah like the the simplest answer
could just be like oh well you know if
if hypertrophy is what you're concerned
about
um
maybe just like bench more like the
typical bodybuilder bench setup than the
typical power lifter bench setup and
that that might do uh a lot of the work
for you
um
but yeah then would would a low incline
counteract that and like I don't know
potentially maybe subjectively I really
like low incline bench I I've talked
about this on the podcast before
um low incline is my favorite barbell
pressing variation don't really like
flat bench don't really like a standard
like 45 degree incline really like low
incline
um but that's like that's a purely
subjective thing like it it just feels
good to me
um I could see it being
slightly better than flat in a somewhat
generalizable sense not maybe for some
of the considerations in this question
or I think more likely just because it
allows for a slightly longer range of
motion like with uh with flat bench
especially if you have a bit of an arch
and you're touching around like your
lower sternum or uh like upper stomach
area I mean that that's limiting range
of motion like range of motion seems
pretty important for hypertrophy with a
low incline you're you're not touching
low on your sternum like it forces you
to touch like nipple line or slightly
above so like that's that's just
necessarily going to lead to a slightly
longer range of motion both for uh both
for your pecs and your triceps like more
elbow flexion more uh more horizontal
abduction so yeah like I I think that it
is it is probably better
um that that is my suspicion but I I
would chalk it up more to just range of
motion than than anything else yeah and
I do want to clarify Jason as I was
reading your question I stumbled over it
it was very challenging for me to read
and speak at the same time I don't want
it to seem like I'm disparaging the
question because I do think it's a very
good question
um but you know reading is not an easy
thing to do especially in front of a
microphone
um so yeah I I also really like the low
incline I guess I can kind of get on
board with the the spirit of the
question because like if I do a ton of
flat bench pressing and really hammer it
over and over and over sometimes my
right shoulder you know it does start to
you know get a little bit angry with me
um and and part of that is because Greg
as you know I'm like a pretty flat bench
or flat flat back venture so for me flat
benching because I'm not doing a lot of
arching you know it it can kind of to
chew up my shoulder a little bit and I
do have a pre-existing shoulder injury
that's kind of a funny story in and of
itself but I I do lean a lot on the low
incline bench because I am able to you
know I'm very hypertrophy focused I'm
targeting the musculature I'm trying to
Target and it does seem to make my
shoulder a little bit happier when I'm
doing low incline versus flat
um but but I do everything in between I
do
the other day for example I went into
the gym I've been doing uh what are they
called a false grip bench press with my
thumb kind of cradling the bar I've been
doing a lot of that but just getting
into it so I was going to bench that day
but my actually my
the chubby little part of my palm where
my thumb goes was actually still very
sore from getting used to having the bar
resting there so I was like you know
what I'm just gonna do some dumbbell
pressing instead and uh so I worked my
way from a super high incline that was
basically like a like a seated shoulder
press you know really high incline and I
just gradually worked my way down to the
lowest incline bench that was doable
with the bench I had
it's simple but man it it's that's a
lovely way to go through a nice push
workout is to start out going from very
high incline all the way to very low
incline moving on doing some other
shoulder and tricep accessories but man
uh it's simple I remember doing it when
I was like 16 years old it was one of
you know my I had a coach I would work
with he's like dude we're gonna just
blast our pecs today and we would do
that but like it gets the job done you
know I I do love a really wide range of
incline pressing
um keeps my shoulder happy and uh yeah
great stimulus for the pecs deltoids Etc
um the story I had the story about my
shoulder injury I always get a little
bit of
a little bit of irritation where my
biceps tendon runs through the shoulder
on the right side I was at a football
camp uh went back when I was playing uh
and the first day of camp I was playing
defensive back I knocked down a pass
SWAT it and land on kind of the point of
my shoulder there you know the classic
kind of tuck and roll over the shoulder
and when I landed I was not wearing
shoulder pads I was like man that that
didn't feel great yeah uh and it but it
was a camp where you like traveled out
you stay in the dorms so it was like
three and a half practices a day
basically all day football and uh man
the next day I'd gone through the first
like two practices and was like dude my
shoulder is not feeling good go to the
uh athletic trainer and they're like oh
yeah I see what's going on no big deal
you're having muscle spasms in your PEC
so I encourage you to ignore it and I
was like all right fair enough like at
that point in my life I took
instructions very well and uh I I had
sufficiently convinced myself damn PEC
spasms hurt a lot but here we are let's
go through it so I finished the rest of
the camp like three practices a day for
the next few days my mother I couldn't
even drive at this point I was so young
my mother comes to pick me up from the
camp and I wasn't wearing a shirt it was
like middle of the summer my right
nipple is like an inch and a half below
my left and she's just walking up to
pick me up was like from like 30 feet
away it's like Jesus Christ what what
happened to you I was like oh Mom this
is what happens when you have a strained
Peck and it's spasming and she's like no
it's not yeah and uh yeah so we went to
the doctor uh separated shoulder and a
broken collarbone and I was playing
football on it for like three days and
uh that didn't help so anyway my
shoulder has never really been the same
after that for a very good reason uh so
yeah I have to I have to baby it in the
gym a little bit but But ultimately it's
not that hard to work around
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than protecting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul provider
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in a applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
all right uh let's see true chains asks
weird ultra-specific question that might
be interesting to ponder I built a
deadlift platform some years ago in my
garage and it turns out the section of
the floor it's on has an approximate
five percent incline when I deadlift I
have to ensure that the loaded barbell
doesn't roll off the platform between
sets it's a bit annoying but I haven't
given it much thought beyond that I've
been dead lifting like this for a couple
years now recently while doing
maintenance calories I ran a deadlift
peaking program my training on this
program the first few weeks was fine not
great part way through I went to visit
my parents and used their local gym my
deadlift numbers improved tremendously
in training sessions blissfully the
floor I was dead lifting on was
completely flat my deadlift training
sessions felt mediocre again when I
returned to my janky platform as dead
lifting on an incline actually affecting
my deadlift numbers or is it just in my
head
yeah I'll take the first swipe at this
it could be any number of things so
um
one it might potentially be a weight
calibration issue
um you know if you have like reasonably
old equipment
um it might be slightly heavy or
alternately uh the weights you used at
the gym that you trained at may have
been slightly light
um most most new plates are actually
calibrated really well but especially
like a lot of like like weight equipment
that you might get from like a garage
sale or a Craigslist sale or something
like that that's 20 30 years old or if
it's just like a like an old commercial
gym uh near near your parents house if
they have old equipment
um there used to be like actually pretty
serious weight calibration issues uh a
YMCA that I used to train at uh their 45
pound plates weighed anywhere from like
37 to 42 pounds like they they were all
underweight some of them to 37 37 wow
like significantly underweight
um which like that's that's extreme too
the 45s wait 37 yeah so so then you make
that big Instagram post after a meet
with calibrated plates where like man I
just didn't have it today yeah dog you
never had it yeah like that was I mean
that was a I think very underfunded YMCA
it had it had some janky ass equipment
it was some brand that I had never seen
before and have never seen since yeah
um but yeah so so that is one potential
uh explanation another potential
explanation is uh you noted that you you
train in your garage and temperature can
have an impact it can have like a pretty
notable impact on performance
um so particularly if it's cold
um
if it's cold man I I have such issues
like working out in a garage and just
getting my body ready to deadlift and
and perform well
um and that that's like that's a that's
a pretty generalizable thing so if you
know if you live somewhere where it's
reasonably cold and you have this
experience in like the fall winter early
spring
um it's chilly in your garage room temp
in the gym like that can absolutely
contribute or conversely like if it was
during the summer and it was really hot
uh short-term uh resistance training in
the heat does actually improve force and
power output a little bit assuming it's
not ridiculously hot so I'm talking like
85 90 degrees if it's like 105 degrees
like ah no like that's you're you're not
going to perform at your best there
um but if it's like a kind of high
volume program like you'll you'll
definitely fatigue faster in in pretty
noteworthy heat than you would which
which might reduce the percent exception
of like the overall quality of the
session even if like the first set or
two goes pretty well
um but yeah then beyond that uh just
addressing the incline itself so I
wanted to start by by ruling out some
other potential confounders that that
may matter more than the incline but as
far as the incline goes I think it would
depend in large part on uh how you
oriented the bar relative to like the
slope of the platform so if you're
uphill of the bar like the bar is trying
to roll away from you then in effect
it's like you're dead lifting with a
slight heel lift and also with a slight
decline because the bars like lower than
the center of pressure of your foot
um
so if that's how you generally set up
you could test this for yourself uh the
next time you go to a gym with a flat
deadlift platform
um elevate your heels slightly and
deadlift with like a half inch or a one
inch deficit and see if that feels
similar to training in your gym if it
does then yeah that's probably what's
going on uh and the opposite could also
be true so if the bar is uphill of you
and it's like trying to roll into you
um yeah that would essentially be like
dead lifting with your toes slightly
elevated from like a a like a very low
block pull it might be hard to find like
the Low Blocks but you you could
certainly try that out for yourself just
the next time you deadlift with a flat
platform uh yeah just just Elevate the
balls of your feet on maybe like five
pound plates or even two and a half
pound plates and see if that affects how
it feels speaking for myself I do think
that both of those things would affect
my deadlift
um and that could just be that I I've
always pulled in either flat soles or
Barefoot on flat ground but yeah when so
I when I used to dabble with
weightlifting a while back and also just
when I used to do a lot more front
squats and just like didn't want to
change shoes between squats and
deadlifts
um like my deadlifts just felt worse
when I was pulling with a raised heel
um and I've also done a fair bit of
um
like rdls with my toes elevated uh for
for whatever reason I just feel a deeper
stretch in my hamstrings when I do that
I'm not entirely sure why
um some people I've seen claim that that
is not in fact a muscle stretch but
you're actually just like
uh like like putting the nerves at a
slightly longer length and you're
feeling a nerve stretch
um or I I think it's also plausible that
like there are like fascial connections
kind of all the way down your posterior
chain and so if you're putting your
calves in a little bit of of a stretch
like your hamstrings will also feel that
stretch a little bit
um regardless I I like toe elevated rdls
but uh yeah my performance is certainly
worse with my toes elevated I'm just
doing that with like pretty low to
moderate loads for reps uh but yeah if I
had to pull a one rep max with my toes
slightly elevated I think that would
hinder my performance quite a bit
um but yeah like you you can test that
for yourself as well so I uh yeah I
think there that there are certainly con
potential confounders in this situation
um but I I do also think it's it's very
plausible that the slight incline itself
uh could be playing a role and uh yeah
next time you pull on a flat platform uh
you you can try some of those things to
test it for yourself
I can tell you I've deadlifted in some
crappy situations where the Bars were
rolling all over the place uh when a bar
is rolling away from me it drives me
nuts with a deadlift uh part it could be
totally subjective I hate it
um
Honestly though dead lifting with an
elevated heel
I would say I certainly don't mind it
and I might actually prefer it I think I
have relatively
poor ankle Mobility such that having a
slight heel elevation like a half inch
heel
my I I have the old Adidas shoes with a
half inch heel instead of the
three-quarter the Adidas power lift yeah
nice yeah which I really like those
shoes but the half inch heel I actually
really like dead lifting with those
um again I'm kind of on the fence if I
find it to be the same or slightly
better but if I had a client
who who reported this kind of thing and
it was just driving them nuts or if I
was in this situation I think one thing
I would do is I would make it such that
I was dead lifting in the direction
where it was a decline so the ball is
the ball the bar is rolling toward me
and my my toes are kind of higher than
my heels and I would just wear an a
slight elevated heel shoe like uh you
know like a like a half inch heel or if
if you got it and I would just see how
that feels because I actually think that
feel pretty lovely for me so uh you know
there's some ways you could try to work
with this and and check out the
situation you know try some things
facing this direction or that direction
elevating the heel to to try to account
for things but yeah I mean that would be
my first thing that I would try
personally and then I have access to
those shoes so easy for me to say but um
but yeah if you can find some reasonably
priced uh uh Olympic weightlifting shoes
with a little bit of a heel elevation it
might not be the it might be a pretty
comfortable solution
all right uh uh let's see question from
Dan to wrap us up all right cool uh so
Dan says I know you've addressed this
before but I wonder if your answers have
changed since you last answered it
particularly given Eric's recent
Enlightenment status uh once again
congratulations for completing the road
to Enlightenment record time uh how do
you guys manage work-life balance
between all the research for Mass
Stronger by science coaching slash
company stuff macro Factor the podcast
speaking engagements Etc if I was in
your guy's shoes I could imagine being a
bit overwhelmed by it all so first off
uh thanks for the question Dan that last
uh paragraph was almost entirely
flattery which will get you everywhere
in life and we certainly appreciate it
uh so do you wanna do you want to lead
off Eric yes I'm gonna keep this pretty
concise this is the type of question
where it can be tempting to kind of go
on and on and on
I would kind of view this as two
separate topics whenever I think about
work-life balance I think first there's
the um the element of just kind of
coping with the workload and the stress
associated with with stuff uh
professionally and then actually taking
proactive steps to facilitate work-life
balance
um so when it comes to coping with a
high workload or a high stress working
situation I try to focus on three things
and I just started reading a book I
haven't finished it yet and I'm sure I
will answer this question
more effectively after I'm done with the
book
but I'm reading the book by ticknot Han
called how to focus and
it's kind of comical that I haven't
finished the book yet because it is very
tiny so I I want to get out ahead of the
Judgment that I'm going to face for that
it's like the side the dimensions are
like the size of a postcard and it's not
many pages so you know whatever it is
what it is but
um yeah it's called how to focus and and
it kind of talks about
uh
obviously focusing but really getting
yourself to move and do some some work
uh at least some of the passages I've
gotten to so far
and there there's a few things that that
jump out to me when I read through that
book and when I think through situations
um you know in my own career things that
have helped me cope with a high workload
or a stressful environment uh number one
trying to be really passionate so trying
to cultivate a high level of passion for
what you're doing now you could be
cultivating a high level of passion and
enthusiasm about the task itself
or perhaps the task itself is boring as
hell and you have to try to cultivate a
lot of enthusiasm about the reason
behind the task you know there are some
things we do for a business that are not
fun but they are critical for the
broader pick you know the bigger picture
the broader goal so trying to cultivate
a lot of passion and enthusiasm for what
I'm doing rather than saying how do I
alleviate stress or how do I trim
workload I try to focus more on how do I
amplify my level of passion and
enthusiasm another thing that I try to
cultivate is curiosity uh and that comes
in when you do all of the research
related work that we do you know
sometimes you can get in a situation
where you're saying I feel like I'm just
like trying to hit this quota of content
right where you're like I just have to
push through and create things for the
sake of having created things I notice
whenever I get to that mindset this is
where I really start to feel you know
the workload and the stress and I try to
take it a step back and simply Embrace a
level of curiosity about the work that
I'm doing what can I learn from this you
know how can this work uh really be
insightful and Illuminating and how
might I truly learn new things from what
I'm doing so curiosity is huge and then
um the third thing is instead of you
know sometimes when we're we're really
burdened by a huge workload or a really
high stress work situation we focus a
lot on the effort or the time or the
stakes of what we're doing and I try to
shift my perspective and focus more on
the impact so I don't think about what
if I don't finish this on time what if I
do it too poorly what if people
criticize it I shift my focus and say if
this goes well and is done effectively
what is the upside you know in what ways
will this be beneficial and impactful
for the people that it's being made for
so trying to focus on passion curiosity
and impact those are the three things
that I really prioritize now when it
comes to facilitating work-life balance
and trying to be proactive about that uh
number one I think it's a good idea to
look for genuine waste in your day and
your habits and trim it and
what is waste that becomes really
subjective it's kind of difficult to say
um you know because I I also have read
another book by ticknot Han called how
to relax and
relaxing resting for its own sake can be
a really helpful thing it can be very
very restorative but I've tried to think
about what is my high quality rest and
what is my low quality rest so like
if I'm truly sitting in silence and
enjoying a cup of coffee that can be
really restorative rest if I think I'm
having down time and I'm just like
playing the TV in the background and
listening to the chatter but really I'm
just thinking about the work I have to
do tomorrow that is [ __ ] that that is
low quality rest that is not restorative
it's not really doing what I want rest
to do for me so I'm not saying that you
should never rest I'm saying that your
rest should be really really high
quality rest right it should really mean
something and make an impact so if you
if you can find areas where there is
just genuine waste in your day where
you're like that's supposed to be
restorative and I'm not getting anything
back from it cut it uh any major
inefficiencies in your schedule try to
cut them to the extent that you can uh
and like I said leisure time is not
something that is to be necessarily
minimized or resting time but you need
to make the most of it like I used to be
very obsessed with efficiency and I'm
glad to say that that's uh
not really where my head's at anymore
like I obviously efficiency is important
but I used to be hyper focused on
efficiency and there was a great quote
in one of Tick's books where someone was
like
you know take not Han zen master monk uh
poet scholar did a lot of things uh
peace activists the whole deal
um but he really likes gardening
and someone was talking to him and they
said tick you got to stop with the
gardening [ __ ] anyone can grow lettuce
you need to be doing your scholarly work
and you need to be writing your poems
because you're a good scholar you're a
good poet anyone can grow this freaking
lettuce so cut it out and he said I
can't write poems if I don't grow
lettuce it it is baked into who I am you
need to have rest you need to have
hobbies you need to have Leisure Time
that is restorative so you can bring
your full self and be your best when
you're doing the stuff that actually
employs you yeah
um number two I think you need to plan
uh family events and social events
pretty ambitiously sometimes I fall
short of this but I'm also very
introverted so my appetite for for a lot
of uh you know social interaction is a
bit lower than most
um
but a lot of times I I have found that
when I really get down to it and I say
no I don't have time for that I don't
have time for that if I just schedule it
and do it
the other stuff will get done you know
you you it's it's kind of like how
sometimes when you are sleep restricted
you'll notice that there are actually
objective increases in sleep efficiency
to try to like kind of make up for that
what I find is if I go ahead and
schedule the family time or the social
time my work
efficiency can increase to the point
where I still get the same amount done
without quality being impacted I just
get it done in a slightly tighter time
window there's less wasted time during
that work effort uh and then another
thing the final thing I'll say with work
life balance is that um
sometimes you just gotta say no to
things and this is something I struggle
with but whenever I'm struggling I come
back to the fact that
even if you don't verbally say no to
things you're still saying no to things
because when someone brings an
opportunity to your inbox and you say
yes to it
even though you might not think about it
you might not verbalize it you're
actually saying no to a lot of different
things whatever you've just committed to
and said yes to you have said no to
every other thing that could have filled
that that space in terms of time and
effort yeah so you think you're saying
yes to everything but you're actually
saying no to way more things than you're
saying yes to you're just not thinking
of it that way so uh being really
thoughtful about
where am I going to allocate my time and
effort and when the time is right
sometimes you just gotta you just gotta
say no
uh what do you got for this one
yeah so I
um
I used to answer this question
by just saying like ah I don't really
have much work-life balance I'm a
workaholic that's just how I'm wired
I've done a bit of introspection and I
don't actually think that's true
um because I mean that was that was
never historically true for me I was a
very lazy student as I mentioned on the
podcast many times before I was a dog
[ __ ] employee at every job I ever worked
um yeah I I don't think I I am just like
congenitally wired to be a to be a
workaholic
um
but so I I was thinking about this a
little bit more and I actually think
that it makes a lot of sense in the
context of self-determination Theory so
uh like the Three core tenets of
self-determination Theory are autonomy
competence and relatedness
um and and looking at my job and what I
do now uh autonomy there's plenty
um all of the companies I'm involved
with uh I'm a co-owner I don't have a
boss
um you know I work on teams I can't I'm
not just completely a free agent doing
anything I want but I I do have pretty
broad autonomy
um to to do most of the things I want to
do and spend most of my time the way I
want to spend it uh competence is the
second uh kind of core tenet of
self-determination Theory and most of
what I do is intellectually engaging and
interesting like a pretty big part of my
job is trying to learn new things well
enough that I can communicate them to
other people which is
um you know that that's that's a
competence Pursuit and then uh a good
chunk of the rest of what I do is like
interacting with people who consume the
content uh which I mean like there's
there's a competence element of that as
well like like figure like not just
learning the stuff but kind of iterating
and trying to figure out how to convey
ideas as well as possible and I've been
thinking a lot more about the
communication aspect recently as as some
of the rants I've gone on in the last
couple of podcasts uh might suggest like
I I do think that it's a
legitimately challenging but also
interesting problem to figure out how to
communicate things with depth and Nuance
in a way that
is still
um that like will still have reach you
know like I think that that's an
interesting project to work on
um
so yeah like there there are certainly
just kind of like more Mindless aspects
of of my job and what I do day to day
but uh relatively speaking like not a
ton like like most of it
um is is kind of related to a competence
Pursuit like they're they're it's not
it's not just things that can turn my
brain off and do on autopilot uh some
some of them I can but it is more fun
and engaging and just better if I
approach it more is like hey here's here
is an opportunity to practice this skill
like try to you know try this new uh
like like try a different idea for how I
might communicate this and see if it
seems to resonate better uh and then you
know once again just trying to learn new
things which I I think is is inherently
interesting to people
um and then the the last element of
self-determination theory is relatedness
um which
largely relates to like doing things
socially
um you know be being around and spending
time with people you like and value and
uh yeah I mean like like I said
um all of the work I do is in teams and
I like all of the people and all of the
teams I work on like I like you I like
Lindsay
um I like Mike uh this contradicts the
lore of the podcast but I I do actually
like Eric Helms to the extent that it's
useful correct
um like Corey like Rebecca uh the devs
from macro Factor like
um I like Adam who does uh support for
Stronger by science and macro Factor uh
I like all of our coaches like I don't
know like I I I am a very social person
and
um yeah I I like all of the people I
work with which uh which is great and I
mean even even when there's not like a
team thing going on like you come over
to work Monday Wednesday Friday but uh
and and we meet with Corey and Rebecca
every so often but you know even when uh
it's not like a a team meeting I mean
I'm still I'm still working in in the
room next door with Lindsay who uh yeah
is my wife I love her very much also my
best friend also uh I I work with her in
all of the things I do so yeah there's
there's like a big relatedness component
there as well and so yeah like I
um I mean not to mention I mean
interacting with all of the like readers
and listeners like that's another
element too yeah I know I like at least
40 of them like they're no I'm I'm
joking it's
probably closer to like 85 if I'm being
completely honest there are some
stinkers if you're listening not talking
about you yeah
um
but yeah so it
um most of the work I do satisfies uh
most of the components of
self-determination Theory and so like
from the outside looking in it still
probably looks like I have pretty dog
[ __ ] work-life balance but also
most of the things related to my work uh
kind of meet those core psychological
needs
um
and so like I like them I don't know uh
like there there are certainly plenty of
things that I would rather do than work
so you know uh uh time with family time
with friends that is completely divorced
from any work obligation uh like you
mentioned and so I you know certainly
make time for that I I value and cherish
that stuff that's very important but
when it comes to work life balance like
you know could I end work two hours
earlier and take up some other hobby
like I don't know maybe but also
uh
like Lindsay and I have fairly different
interests
um it would like I could certainly go
and like make more friends to to do like
another social hobby with people but
also like I don't know like I I like my
family like the friends I have
um you know I I don't feel like I have a
huge dearth of friends and that I like
need to go out and make more so like
that might be fun but I I don't feel a
need to do it I guess
and so like yeah I think for the most
part uh the work I do satisfies a lot of
those just like core psychological needs
that people have
um and so I would just prefer to do it
relative to a lot of the other
Alternatives of of ways that I could be
spending my time so
yeah I I work a lot but I I genuinely
enjoy what I do
um and if the details of my job were
very different uh I might pursue more
robust uh work-life balance as it's
traditionally defined yeah yeah I
definitely Echo that I mean like
uh most of our work
really lends itself to intrinsic
motivation
um but even on the times where you're
like I'm struggling to approach this
task with
passion enthusiasm curiosity I'm
struggling to see the broader impact of
it there is still that element where
much like yourself I just really like
the people that I work with and uh so
that makes it even easier to say
for the team let's pull it together and
do a really good job on this you know
but but I could definitely see like you
said if if the work situation were a
little bit different and we didn't have
a high level of autonomy and relatedness
if we didn't really feel
like our work was benefiting an employer
that really appreciated us or viewed us
as a human being like yeah it could be
quite different but yeah like I do I I
would not willingly put in the same
quality of work and the same number of
hours for a [ __ ] greedy capitalist
swine who is expropriating like 60 of my
Surplus labor value correct yes so I I
do feel um on the one hand a little
hypocritical talking about oh here's how
you create work-life balance because
much like yourself I do work
considerably more than the typical
average like 40 hour work week but at
the same time I I view it as a
psychologically completely different
thing uh within the context of what we
do
um so I'm I'm happy as a clam liking it
but but it was interesting
um
because there was a time where uh I I
had family staying locally for an
extended period of time and I had to
explain like so
you're gonna think I'm a degenerate
based on just the hours I keep like
you're you're gonna text me sometimes at
nine a.m and get a text back at 11 PM
where I say hey what's going on like it
yeah sometimes I just get really
consumed in it um but but it's usually
because of passion not stress and panic
and all that kind of stuff but yeah I
was like I had to kind of like say like
I know it's gonna seem like my life
sucks but it's actually really great
like I really like what we're doing and
that's why I do it a lot
um but yeah so hopefully some of those
tips were uh generalizable outside of
the context of what we do or can at
least help people uh maybe consider like
ways to make their work situation more
uh more conducive to their own happiness
and fulfillment you know yeah and just
as one uh one I guess final parting
thought on this
um like I I will readily acknowledge
that we are both
incredibly fortunate with our with our
work situation
um
and one of the things that we've that we
have been like kind of snarky about on
on the podcast before and I think with
good reason is just kind of like the the
idea of hustle culture
um
and especially like as that relates to
social media content like all like all
of like this thing about the memes yeah
like the the sigma grind set memes
um
but what I will say is like I I think
that there's I think a lot of that stuff
is
um I don't know just kind of like
valorizing work and putting in long
hours for its own sake
um and is also just kind of like oh yeah
like like do do this because it's uh
going to make you a lot of money and uh
money's good and and there's certainly
no reason to think about that further uh
you know it's it's absolutely good and
really the only thing you should be
pursuing and that's that and let's not
think about it anymore because this is
this is supposed to be a meme that uh
you know uh it gets you to hustle and
grind or whatever but what I will say
is that I do think that there is like an
element of that that does kind of make
sense like if you have a work situation
where like you know those those uh needs
of like competence autonomy relatedness
like aren't being met at your job
um you know you have a manager who's
like micromanaging everything you do
you're doing just kind of like Mindless
repetitive work where you know there's
not much space at all to pursue
increased confidence like you're you're
essentially just a human machine you
know
um or you're working in kind of like an
isolated cubicle there's there's no real
um sort of like team feeling
um with with like your co-workers and
like a sense of camaraderie there like I
I do like absolutely understand why
people want to uh like develop a side
hustle to get out of that as quickly as
they can
um and so yeah if if that's if that's
something you're interested in I uh
support you 100 but
um I still think most of the people
making content in that space are
charlatans but very funny yeah yeah no I
I respect the effort towards side
hustles for sure
uh but some of the memes are just
comically terrible they're they're so
good they're so good man all right
um I think that does it for this episode
of The Stronger by science podcast as
always uh we really appreciate for you
for listening but one thing I almost
forgot to mention
you're you're getting this episode on
the 28th of November which means it is
the final day of the mass Black Friday
sale lowest prices of the Year proceeds
a part of the proceeds do support
charity that fights hunger during the
holidays so it's a great cause it's a
great product if you're interested go to
strongerbyscience.com mass to check it
out and learn more like I said the Black
Friday sale ends today November 28th uh
once again thanks so much for joining us
and we'll be back soon with another
episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules we
hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
can sign up for the free newsletter at
strongerbuyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]